how far she has come
receive this ring a symbol of Royal
dignity and a sign of the Covenant sworn
this day
[Music]
the monarchy
Camilla's transformation is complete
a woman who's evolved in the public eye
quietly in the background an image of
almost pantomime villain to Queen
her trajectory is extraordinary and I
first met her in the 1990s and she was
really reviled but I really liked her
from the moment I met her because she's
so self-deprecating she does not suffer
from an irony deficiency fabulous sense
of humor I don't think she could ever
have imagined that the public would take
her into their hearts the way they have
but they have because she's very
authentic
theirs was a complicated love story that
began in the 70s with a secret affair
years later during Charles marriage to
Diana
divorced and six years after going
public Charles and Camilla married and
it was their wedding carefully
orchestrated with the help of press
secretary at the time Patrick Harrison
that marked the start of Camilla's
reintroduction to public life on a
global stage I think everybody would
agree she dazzled on the day and and I
think people very much warmed to her as
often with these big events as quite a
lot of build up some criticism and
discussion beforehand but when the big
day came she was received overwhelmingly
positively
almost two decades on another momentous
day for a blended royal family
accompanying Camilla her grandsons and
Grand nephew the pages of honor and her
sister Annabelle and close friend the
martianess of Lansdowne by her side
throughout the day from The Abbey to the
balcony from Queen consort to Queen
overstated just how significant a moment
this is for Camilla yes she's been on
the balcony before but now it's with a
crown upon her head the end of a long
and turbulent Journey that cements her
place as an integral and equal part of
History unfolding here
out on the streets decades after she was
derided as the most hated woman in
Britain public opinion has mostly
softened I think it is a generation
thing we didn't live through the whole
day in our Saga yeah so we have a
different Insight on like she's not done
anything wrong not quite there I don't
think Queen I think Queen console I I'll
go with no problem at all Queen I don't
think so she has learned from the past
all the lessons uh so I think she will
be a good Queen for all of us they're a
Duo but Camilla Champions her own causes
no longer part of the subplot she's
center stage in what many see as a love
story that stood the test of time Adele
Robinson Sky News London